I hear the new iPhone’s got an amazing sexting
camera...I mean selfie cam.
Hi everyone it’s Ali for D News.
Sexting is super controversial and yet it
happens all the time!
Sexting = sex + texting.
But this can mean a lot of things.
Dirty talk over texts, risque photos, or stripping
selfies.
Today I’m going to focus on sending and
receiving nudie pics.
In a recent review of the research, Deakin
University psychologists discovered that 12%
of teenagers send dirty digital images and
around 12% of teens receive them.
The data skyrockets when you look at young
adults - almost 49% of young adults send and
57% receive sexts.
That’s a lot of naughty bits getting sent
around the interwebs!
People who do this aren’t dumb, they know
bad things can happen.
75% of teens and and 71% of young adults understand
the consequences.
Private photos could get passed along to other
people and that might lead to bullying and
sexual abuse, your phone could be hacked and
things get leaked to the public, your ex could
blackmail you, as former congressman Anthony
Weiner taught us, you can lose your job over
a sext, and if you’re under 18 you might
get sent to jail for having “child porn”.
Just think about that for a moment - in most
states two consenting 16 year olds can have
sex but if they take photos they’re breaking
the law.
Some states are trying to change the laws
on sexting so if minors are caught they have
to pay a fine, do community service, and attend
a prevention program.
Embarrassing yes, but better than a criminal
offense.
There’s no one reason why people sext.
85% do it to because they want to start sexy
time.
80% want attention from their partner.
65% are just flirting.
30% send sexts because they’re pressured
to.
It’s not just people who are hooking up
- a lot of couples in long term relationships
send naked photos to stay connected when they’re
away from each other.
You’ve heard the horror stories - someone,
usually a woman, is pressured into sending
a nude photo, and then that photo gets shared
all over the place.
That does happen - about 17% of people who
receive a sext share it with their friends
to show off, make a joke, or do it out of
boredom.
And yes, it seems like males are more likely
to pressure females by sending them texts
like, “Show me your boobs!
You’re only sending it to me.
I’ll delete it after I see it!
Don’t be all stuck up”.
Giving in to the pressure is risky.
Social media makes it easy to share photos
and people can this without having to interact
with you in person.
That removes empathy and guilt from the equation
which would normally keep people from breaking
your trust.
But most sexts end up just where they’re
supposed to.
Under the right circumstances, sexy texts
can lead to a sexy relationship.
Drexel University’s Emily Stasko and Pamela
Geller recently completed a study of 870 adults
between the ages of 18 and 82.
Yes - senior citizens sext too, don’t be
all agist people!
What they found is not only did 88% of their
sample try sexting at least once in their
lives, but those who did had higher levels
of sexual satisfaction.
This relationship was stronger for those in
committed relationships as long as the both
wanted to dabble in some smartphone sexiness.
If one person wanted to sext but the other
didn’t, it was related to lower levels of
satisfaction.
If this finding continues to pan out in future
studies, then sexting might get incorporated
into couples therapy as a way of increasing
intimacy.
Sexting is here to stay folks.
It’s easy to do and our culture is beginning
to change its views on nude images.
That’s why the Miss America CEO recently
apologized to Vanessa Williams for taking
away her crown 32 years ago after nude photos
of her were published.
The real issue is consent - is this something
both individuals want to do or is something
you are being pressured to do?
If you think about it like that, then sexting
is just another aspect of normal human sexual
behavior and part of a larger discussion we
need to have about consent.
What do you think about sexting?
Let me know in the comments below.
And if you wanna know more about how normal,
plain-old, non-dirty TEXTING affects our relationships,
check out this DNews video right here:
We’ll put a link to that video in the description
if you’re on mobile.
Thanks for watching and don’t forget to
subscribe for more DNews every day of the
week.
Thanks for watching and keep coming back here
to Test Tube for more DNews every day of the
week.
What do you think about sexting?
Let us know on the Discovery News Facebook
page or you can find us on Twitter @DNews.
And you can find me @alimattu.
Thanks for watching!